After four seasons and innumerable betrayals,
the succeeding CEO of Waystar RoyCo has finally
been revealed. But could the end of the show
have been under our noses the whole time?
Since Succession began, the question on viewers'
minds is who would ultimately carry on the Waystar
RoyCo legacy after family patriarch Logan Roy
inevitably had to step down. Turns out, the mighty
CEO stepped down sooner than anticipated, as Logan
died in the third episode of Season 4. Since that
point, it's been a mad dash to acquire power
among the Roy siblings, and the series finale,
"With Open Eyes," finally brought things
to a close the only way it was possible.
Tom Wambsgans ultimately receives an offer
to become CEO, which the Roy siblings try to
circumnavigate. However, at the last second,
Tom's wife, Shiv, sides with her husband — or
against her brother Kendall, depending on how you
look at it — allowing Tom to acquire the position.
Throughout the run of the show, there were
various fan theories suggesting Tom would end up
victorious over the Roy children. After all, Logan
appeared to take a real shine to him throughout
the series. He even calls Tom "son" at one point,
albeit at a time when he was not entirely lucid.
However, one theory that came out just
before the finale aired suggests the answer
was right before our eyes the whole time,
whether the showrunners realized it or not.
Names in prestigious TV shows tend to
carry additional meaning. In Succession,
the last name "Roy" literally translates to
"King," so it's easy to see the symbolism
there. Additionally, Tom's wife goes
by the nickname, Shiv, meaning knife,
which is appropriate for someone who's not
above using underhandedness to get her way.
Even in the series finale, one could argue
she stabbed her brother in the back so that
her husband would become CEO. However, the last
name Wambsgans should've told everyone what to
expect from the moment he was introduced. Sophie
Kihm, the editor-in-chief at Nameberry, posted a
TikTok a few days before the finale offering a
significant hint why Tom would be the new CEO.
Working for Nameberry, she naturally
points to how names have meaning,
and while "Wambsgans" isn't significant
on its own, it does tie Tom to someone
who would mirror his own arc — baseball player
Bill Wambsganss. While the real-life athlete
is spelled slightly different from the
erratic head of ATN, with two esses at
the end instead of one, Bill did something
Tom would achieve in a different context.
In the TikTok, Kihm explains that Wambsganss
was a baseball player best known for being
the only player in history to complete
an unassisted triple play during a World
Series game. In a baseball game, a triple play
occurs when all three outs are recorded on one
single swing of the bat – it’s incredibly
rare to be done by one single fielder,
hence the term ‘unassisted triple play.’ It's
only been done 15 times throughout the sport's
history, and Wambsganss did it during
baseball's equivalent of a series finale.
In the Succession finale, Tom achieves
a similar feat by knocking all three
Roy siblings out of contention for CEO at once.
"Shiv, you should probably know: it's me."
He even bested Kendall's attempt
to subvert his ascension,
with the final vote coming down to Shiv, who
may or may not have considered Tom to be a
better CEO than her brother — either
way, she had to stop Kendall's rise.
Tom's journey to the top spot can be charted
back to the Season 3 finale, when he ratted
out all three Roy siblings to Logan, making
a play that cut all three out of the running.
As Kihm explains, it's important to
make a note of unusual surnames in
film and television. "Wambsgans"
always stood out, but even though
it matches his character arc perfectly,
executive producer Frank Rich told Slate,
"I hate to spoil the internet's fun,
but it's false [...] Tom's family name was
picked before we had shot a first season."
He went on to mention how many writers
for the show are British and therefore
likely wouldn't be up-to-date with
obscure American baseball names.
It just so happens to be one of the
biggest coincidences in TV history.